David and Heather are with us in the
lobby of financial peace Plaza welcome
guys how are you great thank you
well we're honored to have you where are
you from Dubois Pennsylvania
I noticed the Pittsburgh jerseys here
that's we just for you yeah well we
Titans fans appreciate that you're
welcome but I did see the back of them
right debt and free absolutely who's
free I'm free and he's dead absolutely
other way around in real life had to go
for the correction it was going good man
you did that I loved it so much of you
guys paid off a hundred twenty four
thousand seven hundred eighty one
dollars and twenty four cents
I love it how long did it take you it
took us two years in six months good
deal and making what kind of money
during that time we started at 75 and
ended at 86 75 and 86 now how old are
Lena and Travis Lena's 8 and Travis is 4
oh wow have they been practicing the
debt free scream absolutely how are they
gonna do it they got to do good are they
gonna yell loud oh absolutely
you're gonna wring the rafters I love it
very cool like a good Pittsburgh fan
right alright that's good not yet Travis
will tell you he's excited I love it
that's very good did you guys drive from
Pittsburgh to Nashville we did wow
that's a bit of a haul not 10 hours hey
man I tell you so what kind of that was
this hundred twenty-five thousand
dollars well about 80,000 of it was my
student loans and what was that for what
did you get what kind of degree I'm a
teacher okay but I went for further and
got my master's degree and then my
leadership degree okay
cool very cool so you teach now yes the
virtual education in Ridgeway Area
School District oh great great very cool
and what do you do David I work at a
International Thai company where we make
railroad ties I operate machinery yeah
awesome very cool so uh and so 80,000
student loan debt what still the 45
we had some credit card and we had some
stupid tax and we had a loan on our
house that we paid off too so good oh
the house is bait house is paid off too
and no none of it was this debt Wow yeah
we paid cash for our house when we moved
back to my hometown how did you do that
well we sold a house and sold some land
and we took the money and she had some
good equity then absolutely and so
didn't bought a place Wow
free and clear that's amazing absolutely
that is awesome well that's a great
start to and then knock the student
loans out and boom so what happened two
years six months ago that caused you to
say okay we're not gonna be normal
anymore what happened I lost my job oh I
lost my job after 14 years and I was on
my way to my new job and I happened to
listen to this crazy guy in the morning
on the way because they replay it in the
morning where we were from and I got to
listen to you for about a week and I
don't went home told my wife I said we
need to do this and she listened to it
on the way to work and she came home and
said absolutely and that night we were
on a budget ever since so yeah when you
lose your job you're willing listen the
crazy guy the crazy guy is doing
something right crazy like a fox I love
it so what do you tell people the key to
paying off 125,000 dollars in debt is
discipline and focus
I'd say teamwork Bethlem between my wife
and I and the kids they knew what was
expected they always said Dave Ramsey
says it in the budget so we're not going
here we're not going there so they knew
they were and they were integral part of
it so you think they got it enough that
this debt-free scream and this drive ten
hours to get here is all sinking in that
this is a moment in your family's life
absolutely there was a time whenever
Lina wanted ice cream and we said I'm
sorry it's not in the budget it was two
days away from payday and we just didn't
have it in the budget so she said well I
have money can I spend it and get the
family ice cream and I said sure cuz
she's on the junior kit so she has her
spend save and give envelopes as well
what a sweet thing that's some awesome
very cool very cool well we'll give you
a free cookie today Lina so Dorothy
we'll get you all the cookies you want
that's your payback
amazing very very sweet very cool you
guys are a beautiful family you've
obviously done some pretty incredible
things what was the hardest thing you
did or the hardest part of this getting
out of that thing I think the hardest
part was when we were seeing the numbers
go down we were on our last loan and I
said it's not going down fast enough and
I called Kelley Chrysler in Brookville
and said how much will you give me for
my car and then I sold my classic car on
top of it oh so and he sold his
motorcycle and we sold camper Oh
so the hardest part was when the numbers
weren't going down fast enough we had to
be creative and find different ways to
make more money so that they would go
down faster really isn't as creative as
it is just sacrificial well Heather
started crocheting hats for kids and I
started making custom pinata so we were
kind of in the business of whatever we
could do to make an extra 10 bucks if it
wasn't nailed down in our house we sold
it what's the classic car I had a 1970
Mini Cooper S really yeah 70 interesting
yeah okay and what was the motorcycle I
had a Honda Shadow okay and what was the
what was the car you sold to the
Chrysler 2007 dodge charger Wow oh you
got her car family it was it was a Dodge
Charger r/t all-wheel drive and she went
to a 1992 Toyota Camry people thought we
were crazy but we knew that you have to
be crazy for our family you are crazy
you're just completely out of control
but you're not normal anymore
no that's good it's a good thing normal
is looking good with all that junk in
your driveway in your garage broke right
it's honorable to a job loss absolutely
you're not vulnerable anymore no got no
house payment no nothing and young kids
the wealth you guys are gonna be able to
build and the way your family trees
completely changed absolutely amazing
all right Travis you ready to rail debt
you ready to do your debt-free scream
are you have you been practicing just
nod that's good very good all right
David and Heather Lena and Travis a
hundred and twenty-five thousand dollars
paid off in two point
Cheers including ice cream 75 thousand a
year to 86 thousand a year count it down
guys let's hear a great debt free scream
thanks to Dave you guys are awesome and
that's amazing good stuff